pushing golden glue and dota to one side
no chase their baby actually gets into
Gaul it goes down on a breakable will
coming in for dodo double it flashes
over the wall Dublin picks up two more
one of those goes over to afro booze
rush hour comes up chairs dead did we
see here's the claps around them though
we said when with links start on for
other targets oh my god
oh right back into it with fates calling
eternal er gets absolutely shredded by
that Randy is the neck took as well but
they can't follow up man cloud we were
on the same page was in the direction we
wanted to go in the mid under fire CLG
brothers lunch blitz this game shall we
shall goes down that was beautiful the
ballista play pulled off perfectly right
there like the truth is afro went to the
org and he said it's either me or him I
mean Peter could be a dick and talk bad
about everyone that he wants to talk bad
about but ultimately I don't care I feel
like people have a really likes youth
perception of me and after up I mean
that's cool he wants to hate me that's
right to me I feel like he gave up on me
as a friend and as a teammate
organization thought it would be the
best decision moving forward only
because Peter
brings people down more often than not I
think we can all agree that I'm way
better off on TSM and I think Jess M
wins
I win and CLG ultimately wins because if
they really hate me so bad then now they
don't to deal with me
Ephram you wanted something different
doublelift attitude was bringing down
the team and afro wanted to take a
leadership role for everyone he wasn't
just the team's leader he was their big
brother he was mr. CLG this is his story
Zachary afro mu black was born on
September 8 1992 in Whittier California
and took the video games at a young age
afro who played Diablo with his dad and
eventually moved to playing competitive
world of warcraft even playing on a LAN
at Blizzcon but after a move eventually
grew tired of MVP Wow and turned to
League of Legends
afro who started out as a streamer and
gained popularity thanks to a solid
eighty Harry play and allowed
personality no he probably DC for a good
reason maybe maybe some black guys
robbed his house and he got clocked in
the face you don't even know and you
just reported him were a big fight for
real those people those kind of people
just made me so mad
[Music]
[Music]
we're going deep in a pink Oh to the
base but Africa wasn't just a popular
streamer he played at a high level and
pros quickly took notice
unfortunately none of them seemed to
stick an afro Lou joined seven teams
between 2011 and 2012 in late 2012 after
Lou switched from ad carry to support
and though he was playing a less active
role he was still just as good and just
as bombastic like what the [ __ ] are you
doing ter you gonna stop me boy when you
just [ __ ] him up you just [ __ ] them up
like what the [ __ ] back the [ __ ] up but
easy now no you have [ __ ] presence in
the lane dude now you just get in the
[ __ ] bush and then back the [ __ ] up
they want that shooting [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
this guy a flash exhaustion guys and
it's like GG is a pop W and you cut and
you what the [ __ ] the poor is so easy
dude
holy [ __ ] afro move first joined CLG in
December 2012 as their starting support
sharing the ball lane with a man
considered the best ad carry in North
America double left
Oh
[Applause]
CLG placed fourth that season but fell
to last place in the playoffs forcing
them to win their spot in the LCS back
through the promotion tournament now for
CLG the stakes couldn't be higher
on the line for hotshot and crew is not
just a trip to the LCS but the very
existence of the team despite Afra loose
talents the team didn't work and he was
the first to leave the team after they
reek walla fide aphromoo says that he
stepped down that he couldn't handle the
pressure that came with being relied on
by his entire team the pressure of
playing with someone as demanding as
doublelift
steel g replaced aphromoo with founding
member cha stir in may
afro returned to streaming and did that
full-time until october when he tried
out for team curse and made the team
before getting a call from clg's
midlaner link I talked to Link and I saw
doublelift in soloqueue and when we
played bottom lane again I played
support and I guess he remembered me
after that oh yeah the game I guess so
afro mu was back on theology and back
with double been the best ad carry in
North America was back with one of the
league's brightest young support players
it seemed like the perfect match but the
pressure was still on aphromoo was
already on the team before and they
brought him back so that he could play
with double left once again exciting a
lot of fans
doublelift an afro move quickly became
one of the stronger bought lanes in na
and one of the most popular as well as
the years went on they only got better
and their fandom grew even more the pair
played up their friendship for the
camera leaning on their personalities to
create one of the most iconic
partnerships and league of legends rush
hour why did you guys seem like you
wanted to throw that game so badly well
double F didn't please me last night so
I was pretty mad and usually I take out
my rage in bottom Lane and we saw that
today but while support is a selfless
role playing support for dub
is an even more selfless act doublelift
is a hyper carry which means afro mousse
entire job was to set things up for his
80 carry to succeed no roaming no play
making no glory
he gets an ultimate not against the wall
TSM actually blows a few summoners to
get into the right position to be in the
right spot that killed going to them but
dyrus has also fallen that's going to be
pop outs are going down to close now for
CLG triple kill for turtle looking for
the Quadra not gonna get it that time
it's a triple for double if he's like
both players had big personalities but
as they played together more Afro MU
started to mellow out we're double if
got louder afro mu started taking a more
quiet leadership role on the team taking
on shotcalling duties and even getting
more pensive and interviews what are you
guys looking at is kind of your real
opponents right now and who's gonna give
you some trouble
final question honestly I don't really
talk down most of the themes League
they're really good and really fun to
play again it's good policy especially
enemy as you've seen right here
TSM Team Liquid Dignitas enemy and
that's all I can think of right now
they're all looking really good and
they're really fun to play against and
that's all that really matters and we
just have to execute our plan as well as
we can the shot calling position was
taking its toll on Afro mu every season
see LG's team looked strong but they
never quite managed to put together a
win in the playoffs this is gonna be it
they are pushed back to the the fountain
right now Nexus turrets are falling 34
minutes into the game a clean sweep on
counter logic gaming after the bootcamp
in Korea it's not gonna be enough to
stop curse the pressure on Afra mu was
mounting as his team will look to him to
lead them to victory he was still the
same fun-loving guy he was on stream all
those years ago but on stage he was a
professional and he wanted to win in
summer 2015 a fro mu finally got his
wish
CLG looked better than ever they placed
second in the regular season and went
undefeated in the playoffs where they
beat Team solomid 300 in the grand
finals
[Applause]
you'd expect a fro loo to be ecstatic
you'd expect him to be happy but a fro
Moo was just relieved I was just like
whatever I think I realize from the fact
that I know all my teammates they're
happy that we won much though than you
know me being happy that we won you know
I just like seeing them you know excited
and I'm happy that you know all the work
that we put in you know we got to where
we went
CLG went on to Worlds after their win at
MSG but failed to make it out of their
group and things were only gonna get
tougher for Afro mu hey my name is Olaf
and starting today I'll be a part of TSM
doublelift departure wasn't necessarily
his own decision afro mu was the one who
called for a shake-up and CLG like the
truth is afro went to the org and he
said it's either me or him great
branding one of the most popular players
in the league has a great franchise you
know but the trade-off just wasn't that
good I'm not ever gonna deny that I made
a lot of mistakes but the thing is that
I tried really hard to fix them and I
was getting better and improving and
there's like interviews and a lot of
proof where my teammates and coach had
said that I made a lot of progress and I
wasn't just trying to improve I was
improving we tried it for three years I
was on the team for three years
obviously and you know get better little
by little attitude you know but team
chemistry wise and the impact he had on
the team in general just atmosphere wise
being another personal relationship with
people is just it just brings people
down you know every season
Afra mu was given control of a new CLG
team for the upcoming spring season and
was preparing to lane with a fresh-faced
ad carry stick say
[Music]
[Applause]
stakes a was young and new to the
proceeding he had pleaded challenger but
Afra mu was the one who shepherded him
onto the big stage
so when six a came to play he was very
calm mellow and when I play with him in
lane he would kill somebody who I didn't
think we would kill I was like what the
hell dude doesn't what I didn't know you
can do it that guy was insane
after lose sauce sticks a as a younger
brother but he also had plenty to learn
from him breaking free of double lifts
play and attitude let afro Mook come
into his own as a playmaker and
shot-caller going into the back lines
and sneaky gonna get stopped for now can
they go back in rashes dangerously low
despite the triple kill the game goes to
counter logic gaming and they control
second place clg's roster was unproven
but with aphromoo at the helm CLG
quickly became one of the best teams in
the league that season he was proving
that it wasn't just doublelift carrying
CLG he was an important part of the team
success as well up his laning prowess
here and now the push in towards sticks
a doozy our kinship the point-blank
damage so get some episode ulti and
that's gonna be a catch oh just sneaky
here's the real case they get the Bears
clap they get the damage he flashed the
way and does stay alive now hide this
gets crushed that's a play by darshan
who falls could be next to got the stop
the wall and a double kill for darshan
Jackson I thought that he was toast but
very good understanding of a block
that's the kill picked up absolutely
beautiful
half rémoulade CLG to another na LCS
championship this time with a 3-2 win
over TSM in the spring 2016 grand finals
knock back now by Buster shot as well
Pearson is love slow advance and gets it
up put you in this out he's talking at a
shrine arena no again for the race
he's going
Smith these popping up from his GA
Spence cares can try stuff but you can
change the players but the faith remains
and they're gonna walk to their second
consecutive North American LCS
championship and CLG wasn't done the
team went to the midseason Invitational
after playoffs where they were pegged as
one of the weaker teams at the event so
the thing about CLG is I actually don't
think they're a bad team I just have
questions about their team on the
international stage and I think there's
three of them can except up the way you
did in the finals he diversified his
champion pools very well not only
supportive but also very aggressive but
sticks say who he I think that there are
huge questions about who he if he
doesn't get banned out very much what
else can he play and sticks a champion
to a pool to me I don't know whether
it's good or bad but it's bizarre man
but aphromoo led CLG to second place
taking games off of Royal never give up
the flash wolves g2 eSports and SK
Telecom t1 in the process Marin is being
started counter logic gaming are looking
for the purple path
Oh chicken sticks this on the front line
it flashes he's down this double damage
from CLG but who needs the one that has
to do it he's being jumped on by to
thank managed to kill Bank both a nice
ease up there to see al Gina numbers
advantage kills faker council logic
gaming looking for a nice they've got
you chasing him down bounce off the
pounds annex myth the captive for the
third time in two days
CLG will take Ali SKT this is
unbelievable this to go for members up
counter logic gaming are pushing it to
the base Tasha still got a ga
and it's only wolf remaining CLG are on
to the Nexus turrets CLG are pushing SKT
and it looks like they're going to do it
the focus is the Nexus and counter logic
gaming scoring magnificent win last hour
goes down CLG only have the Nexus
turrets are Shawn's in trouble he
decides to engage on wolf informal
suffice
time lamb's respite will keep CLG alive
for a few more seconds but this feels
like the final fight petrifying gaze
didn't lock anyone up but did CLG into
the end he picks his hands up as SKT
I've got four members down they turn
their attention to the Nexus SK Telecom
continued to rule Ephraim ooh wasn't sad
about the loss in fact he said it was an
opportunity to learn and understand
where he had to lead his team to next we
definitely learned a lot and being able
to play against all the teams and making
it all the way to finals we have a lot
of knowledge that we can use for our
play and going into na LCS I think that
na as a region will probably do a lot
better at Worlds this time around
definitely really confident in saying
that afro move proved once again that no
matter what his team looks like no
matter who his opponents are he was too
stabilizing
eating presents the teams need to make
championship runs for his part aphromoo
continued to get more and more measured
in his public appearances he could still
crack a joke but being the guy his
teammates relied on being the most
respected leader in the NA LCS made
aphromoo more pensive more thoughtful I
don't think too much has changed like
with his personality throughout like two
three years I've known him he's been
pretty much the same person but now he's
a lot more like commanding or like
demanding it like what he really wants
and as far as like gameplay or anything
like that goes before he was less of a
natural leader and now he's like a very
like powerful person within the team as
the seasons past aphromoo stuck with CLG
others came and went but a fromyou was
always there he was mr. CLG the team
leader the company man always there as
the star support and
the team looked to when things looked
rough but CLG wasn't winning
championships anymore Ephraim who needed
a shake-up and when na LCS franchising
hit new teams were knocking at his door
I never you know looked at my other
options besides healed you because I
thought that that would be my home
forever but a hundred thieves wanted a
star support they wanted a great leader
who could show a brand new organization
the way they wanted experience and a
stabilizing presence they wanted Africa
we are so incredibly proud and excited
to welcome a promo as the support player
for the hundred these rocks are moving
into the 2018 LCS we got a pro move what
are you eight what are you insane you
you you're doing well there's still a
young team hundred thieves have done
well so far they've beaten CLG with a
fro Lu leading them to victory let's see
what they can find here turret number
one gonna be the target the defense
comes out but it will not stand
reignover down one turret down one
hundred thieves onto the remaining
structure still standing CLG still has
15 seconds before their mid laner comes
alive darshan alone will not hold this
and 100 thieves find their win but more
importantly aphromoo has become the kind
of veteran that he looked up to all
those years ago 6a who you essentially
helped train and grow was playing
against him a proud dad moment or was it
a I'm gonna put this kid in this place
Trevor's a good kid he actually has
really good mechanics it was really hard
to line his skill shot on him usually I
have that on my team for playing on CLG
right but still he's gonna do well they
are a new team coming together from the
jungle and support roles as well but
they just need a little bit of time okay
he has one of the longest careers in
North American League of Legends and has
gone from a goofy streamer to one of the
most respected shot callers in the
league
we don't know how long afro moon will
keep playing but he'll always have a
place as one of the NA LCS is most
important fakers
he might not have dozens of trophies but
he has something just as important the
respect that comes with being the
ultimate support thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button